an aerial view of the kalehe region in
eastern Democratic Republic of Congo
shows the extent of the destruction
caused by last week's landslides
homes schools and markets were Swept
Away
hundreds of people were killed thousands
are missing a major road connecting
South and North kevu provinces was cut
off
volunteers like Amani mulenga are trying
to clear the debris as they look for
more bodies
they are working on a bridge at the
center of the village by its No Easy
Task
this is where most of the water came
flooding through when the river burst
its banks I live near here it's shocking
to see the devastation
people are trying to save what they can
from structures that are barely holding
flood waters came gashing down the hills
bringing with them rocks trees and mud
most survivors are being treated for
broken bones and bruises
some were referred to better equipped
hospitals in the province some of the
injured people are in this health
facility they're recovering well but
doctors say they are running short of
medical supplies and Foods this Health
Center survived the landslide
prudent reggae and other health workers
have been working round the clock for
days
we have no medicine the patients don't
have enough food the government is
helping with that people are traumatized
they need counseling there are not
enough doctors and nurses
people have told us they will rebuild
their homes but they know it's going to
be a long hard journey Catherine soy
yamakubi South kivu Democratic Republic
of Congo
the world health organizations